Aww yeah!
I'm back with another lesson
with Disney movies,
this time with scenes from the classic Frozen
and the new, just-released Frozen II.
This will be a great opportunity for you
to get all warmed up for it
and to learn some specific vocabulary related
to the weather, the seasons, and even poetry.
And if you're new here, every week we help
you to understand fast-speaking natives
without getting lost,
without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles!
Just like Aarsh, who says that we helped
him to pass his recent English exam.
And we'll help you to reach your English
learning goals too —
all you have to do is hit that Subscribe button
and the bell down below
so you don't miss any of our new lessons.
Finally, I've got a very special opportunity
to tell you about in just a little bit.
But, for now, let's jump into this
fun and entertaining lesson with Frozen!
So, you can learn a ton by doing the things
you love, like watching series like Friends,
and movies like Frozen,
but, is it enough?
Well, in my experience learning six
different languages,
I have always found that native media
and keeping it fun are essential parts of the process.
But, sooner or later I would always get stuck.
And this made me lack confidence
because I knew I was making mistakes,
but, I didn't really know what I needed to
focus on learning to correct them.
And my friends weren't correcting me,
and they didn't really know either
how to explain the grammar to me.
So at some point, just music, books,
and series aren't enough.
You need the guidance of a teacher.
So for me, having the guidance of a professional
who has tons of experience helping people
who are having the same learning
challenges is essential,
and that's why I am excited to present
a great new opportunity
from our friends over at Lingoda.
They are going to help you to improve
your speaking skills
and your confidence quickly,
in just a matter of months.
And the great part about this promotion is that
when you fully participate in all of the classes,
you can get a 100% refund!
So, I've tried Lingoda, and it is fantastic!
You get to learn with native teachers anytime you want,
and they give you all of the materials you need
so you know exactly what you need to focus on.
So over the past few years,
Lingoda has helped 20,000 learners just like you
to transform their lives getting opportunities
to work and study abroad.
You can see some of their inspiring stories on
Lingoda's website by clicking the link down below,
and definitely check out their Instagram as well.
So, what exactly is this promotion?
So, Lingoda has a motivating study
challenge called the SPRINT.
And this is really fantastic because
it gets you committed to learning.
As both a coach and a language learner myself,
I know that having this accountability
is absolutely crucial.
Because, otherwise it's too easy to
skip when you're tired or busy.
And with the SUPER SPRINT,
you will be showing up every single day,
and you're going to make
huge progress on your learning.
Unless you do the [regular] SPRINT,
in which you do slightly less classes.
Now, when you complete all of the classes in the
SUPER SPRINT, you will be getting a 100% refund.
And, if you complete the SPRINT,
you'll get a 50% refund.
It's open to all levels, whether you're a beginner,
an intermediate, or advanced.
And the SPRINT begins on January 7th, 2020
and ends on April 5th.
All right, so in order to participate
you have to sign up BEFORE December 19th.
After paying your 49-euro non-refundable deposit fee,
which holds your spot, you will automatically
be signed up for a 3-month subscription.
But don't worry — this deposit goes
towards paying your first month of classes.
And remember that Lingoda will
refund 100% of your tuition fee
if you complete the agreed number of classes.
There's no trick or catch here.
But, be sure to read all of the terms and
conditions
as students say that this is
the key to success in the SPRINT.
And, to make it even better for you, we have
a special discount code for you.
Just click the link down
in the description box below,
and use our code [SPRINT94]
to get 10 euros off of your entry fee.
Now, if you already have good habits learning English with TV series and other native media,
then I think Lingoda's SPRINT can be
a really awesome opportunity for you.
Just imagine if in 3 months, you could
confidently converse with a native.
Or get an exciting new job,
or move to another country.
And you could do it all for FREE
by completing Lingoda's SPRINT.
Best of luck to all of you that participate in the SPRINT,
and now, let's get back to this lesson with Frozen.
Awesome! I hope that you had
a lot of fun with this lesson with Frozen,
and that it'll help you a lot when you
go and see Frozen 2 in theaters.
And remember that if you want to
participate in that Lingoda's SPRINT
that you have to sign up
BEFORE December 19th.
Just imagine by having fun learning English
with series and movies here on our channel,
and by speaking English with
native speakers with Lingoda,
how much your English will have improved
in the next three months.
So, don't wait any longer, click the link
down in the description box,
and remember to use our code [SPRINT94] at checkout
to get 10 euros off your registration.
And remember to also subscribe to our channel
so you don't miss any of our newest lessons.
Now, it's time to go beyond the classroom
and LIVE your English!
Aww yeah!